blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com pakman
well i wish i had something better to
start with today i do
but unfortunately covet cases in the
united states are absolutely
exploding thanks to not having
vaccinated
nearly enough americans yet and because
of the unvaccinated doing things that
they really should not be doing
plus the highly contagious delta variant
and
understandably the vaccinated are
growing
increasingly furious with the
unvaccinated
who refuse to take the steps that
everybody can take
to help end this pandemic i mean aren't
we sick of this
wouldn't you accept and willingly and
excitedly
go towards an action if there was
something you could do
to help end this pandemic they won't get
vaccinated
they won't wear masks and they'll insist
on large gatherings of unvaccinated
people
cnn reporting that some vaccinated
americans
have lost their patience with those
refusing the shot
as covid 19 cases surge and mandates
return we'll tell you in a bit about
what's been going on in florida
the washington post reporting that quote
vaccinated people
are ready for normalcy and angry
at the unvaccinated getting in their way
they claim to want everything to go back
the normal
back to normal and in fact many of them
never thought we needed to depart from
normal even in may june uh whenever of
2020 in the middle of the pandemic they
never wanted to do anything
and yet they won't do the things
that would help us get back to normal
and you know what
it's correct to be resentful of these
people
you know at the start of the pandemic
things
were crazy we didn't know how contagious
or deadly covid was we didn't know how
much social distancing would work or
to what degree masks would mitigate the
spread and
there were differences of opinion in the
midst
of not yet having full information and
while it started to become
clear that there were some bad faith
actors there were
there were still more unknowns about
what needed to be done and then when it
became clear well okay yeah the masks we
need
we need to stop large indoor gatherings
the bleaching your papayas
that didn't make sense but these other
things did
and we learned more and more and they
still didn't do anything
then it was frustrating i think is the
way i would describe it
and then the vaccines became completely
widely available i mean in a way that
other countries can only dream of
and a ton of those other countries are
desperate for vaccines and yet here
you have tens of millions of people who
just won't get vaccinated instead
they are more interested in spreading
vaccine
disinformation and conspiracy theories
wildly
irresponsibly and humiliatingly
that's their choice and so now we have
another surge
it's mostly unvaccinated people
getting sick and and mostly unvaccinated
people getting seriously sick
and overwhelmingly unvaccinated people
dying but
not only covet is here uh
it's endemic and we are now stuck with
these people
in a veritable idiocracy so now it is
anger and now it is reset resentment and
now its fury and its desperation and the
world looks at us and wonders what on
earth is going on over there
we're desperate for vaccines we want oh
wow we just
i think joe biden just sent like four
million
vaccines to nigeria maybe it was you
know small small numbers
we have hundreds of millions you just
walk in and you get vaccinated and
you're almost certain not to get
seriously sick from covid
and they won't do it so i have to tell
you before this pandemic
i knew how partisan and divided the
country was
over political issues but i guess
naively i thought
if something serious happened like a
pandemic
we would come together and do what needs
to be done across
party lines what an idiot i was i mean
boy was i wrong
my faith in even the most basic ability
to count on the united states as a
society
to do simple things wear masks when it
makes sense to wear masks
get yourself vaccinated when you can
which is now for
everybody who's 12 or older play by the
rules don't spread insane conspiracy
theories about a virus
my faith has been completely eroded by
what we've seen i was reminded
of a kurt vonnegut quote that applies
perfectly to our situation here in the
united states
true terror is to wake up one morning
and discover
that your high school class is running
the country now my high school class was
actually okay there were lots of smart
people
but a lot of my high school classmates
are also spreading conspiracies on
facebook
so it's more like we've woken up and the
people who had no business
running a lemonade stand in high school
are now running the country and part of
it has to be
past generations didn't have such ready
access to misinformation
and conspiracies about anything that
happened like they had it with a lot of
stuff there was war propaganda
whatever but now there is no break to
the signal boost
if you get a notion in your head that
the vaccines are evil and bill gates and
whatever
you can just go on facebook or wherever
and you can
find information that just reinforces
that hair brain belief where
in times past on some issues there's
always been propaganda but
on some issues there was not such an
easy way to signal boost
any crazy notion that you had you don't
really want to accept the science well
here's a full social media platform from
uncle bob
when and you can choose to just insulate
yourself
with that stuff so we are in real real
trouble here
and um as as i've been telling you guys
uh
we are starting to see this delta wave
pass in europe i mentioned i'm going to
be in spain next week and we'll
have some great guest hosts here uh it
looks like spain
uk and other places they are they are
seeing a rapid decline
after the delta variant uh took hold
there as
vaccination continues and many of these
countries including spain have surpassed
the us
in percentage of people vaccinated we'll
look at those numbers a little later
it's not clear how long the numbers are
going to continue worsening in the
united states we're at 100 000 cases a
day again
and we'll look at that a little bit
later um
florida it's unconscionable what's
happening
record hospitalizations in florida like
record going all the way back to the
beginning
so we're in real trouble and it's
correct it makes sense
that the resentment of the people who
just choose not to get vaccinated
is growing dramatically now many of you
have been asking
is coveted going to become a republican
virus is this going to become a
republican pandemic in the united states
because
when you look at the numbers if
democrats are getting vaccinated at way
higher rates
than republicans and if blue states have
much more cautious rules about large
indoor gatherings etc
than red states won't it eventually
become a republican pandemic and the
answer is that it overwhelmingly already
is
we have new numbers that philip bump
wrote about in the washington post
which showed that the new infection rate
in the last couple of weeks
is twice as high per capita
in red counties than it is in blue
counties
in the united states so important this
is at the county level
way more precise than the state level
you know the thing about looking at the
state level is
you can have a blue state that's 53 to
46
a state that joe biden won but you might
really have a much more
precise division if you look at red and
blue counties
within that state now some of the
counties might only be slightly blue or
slightly red
but it's a much more accurate and
precise way of slicing and dicing this
and the numbers are shocking in the last
two weeks on average
blue counties are seeing 10 new cases
per hundred thousand residents whereas
red counties
are seeing 20 new cases per 100 000
residents the new case rate in red
counties
counties that voted trump rather than
biden is twice
that of the new case rate in biden
counties
that is a stunning gap and it's actually
you can make the case that the numbers
don't even tell you how bad it is
because when you consider that blue
counties tend to be more densely
populated than red counties
this reflects very poorly on red
counties like
the default position for positivity
rates is that red counties should be
doing
better than blue counties all else being
equal because you have a lower
population density it should be a little
more difficult for it to spread when the
population density is lower
the fact that it the the new case rate
is twice as high
in red counties even despite having
lower population density is incredible
now the other important thing is the
delta variant
which is significantly more contagious
the delta variant is affecting the whole
country
red and blue states red and blue
counties everybody's affected by the
delta variant
but if you consider and compare counties
today versus where they were a year ago
meaning
not only pre-delta but pre-vaccine we
are basically seeing the same partisan
split on average you see uh even
even consider comparing to a year ago
you are seeing dramatically worse
numbers
in the red counties than in the blue
counties now the immediate question is
well how
how is the trump electorate going to
react how are the trump people going to
react well they're already doing it
they are saying the statistics are fake
to make them look bad
uh now that of course would require all
sorts
of conspiracy involving a whole bunch of
different agencies
in multiple states red and blue states
the simpler explanation a sort of casual
occam's razor is
the data might just be real and it
reflects what's happening
within these different places that's the
most intuitive it requires the fewest
assumptions
and it's the simplest explanation so
some people will claim the numbers are
just
fake and they're made up others will
just ignore the statistics
you know it'll it'll and it could shift
over time it might begin with denial
then it will go to anger about the
people making up
numbers to make red states look bad and
then who knows
or they might even invent something
whole cloth
you know biden is bringing infected
immigrants from other countries and
releasing them into red states to drive
up the numbers so something like that
but the truth is this is exactly
what you would expect based on the
different behavior
the different attitudes and the
different vaccination rates
the other thing you might see by the way
the other thing you might see as a
result of this
is some of the red states just clamping
down
on reporting this stuff we're going to
look at covet hell
florida later we still don't even know
if we're getting accurate numbers from
florida
the numbers we're getting are the worst
in the country and the worst that
florida has seen in the pandemic single
day record more than 24 21 000 cases
in a single day over the weekend we
don't even know if these are truly the
numbers that are coming out of florida
um and given their track record it's
really unclear so
it is wild what is going on right now
the world is looking on in horror
the vaccinated are looking at the
unvaccinated and saying what are you
doing
what are you doing and i have actually a
really sort of disturbing voicemail
today
about how we've been talking about
vaccination that'll be a little bit
later but after the break we'll look at
florida
and we'll look at a whole bunch of other
things that took place over the weekend
it is august we are two weeks to the day
from the 16th anniversary of the david
pakman show on that day august 16th two
weeks from today
we will be doing a one day membership
special i want it to be the biggest
one day sign up in the history of the
show
we'll be offering a huge discount on
august 16th
if you'd like to be notified just get on
my newsletter
at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
remember that the david pakman show is
really a program unlike
any other not only because i have no
idea what i'm doing but also because
we're funded directly by our audience
our program is funded by people like you
and you can sign up and grab a
membership at joinpacman.com we do
an extra show every day for folks like
you who sign up
you also get commercial free audio and
video feeds of the show
if you would like them and occasional
member
town halls you can sign up at
joinpackman.com
so this you just have to see to
understand
the complete and total disconnect from
reality that has
infected yeah infected the republican
party
when it comes to the coronavirus
pandemic republican senator ron johnson
appeared on fox news over the weekend
and he was asked
could you ever get a vaccine behind get
behind a vaccine mandate
we know you're not 41 right now but
could you ever get behind
the government mandating that people get
a vaccine
and ron johnson said i mean it's
completely beyond parody
he said i could only do that i could
only support a vaccine mandate
if there was a deadly disease spreading
now of course he means more deadly than
covid
let's take a look at the video and then
discuss you see
that if you have this virus and you
spread the virus and you're unvaccinated
you have a chance of being a better
chance of being hospitalized
but i don't think you can mandate
someone get vaccinated
i'm pretty sure that we've never done
that before and it was a month ago
when both kamala harris and the
president said i can't force anyone to
do it
but europe is doing that could you ever
get behind a vaccine mandate for
everybody
no not unless there's some incredibly
deadly disease
i mean much higher infection fatality
rates that we have with
covert we don't know the final infection
of childhood
so he says he could only get behind a
vaccine mandate
if there was something really deadly
spreading
to which he clearly is is referring uh
uh to something
much deadlier than covid and then he
later on went on to say i'm not
downplaying covid but
you know something about the fatality
rate of the flu he said now let's let's
break this down in parts this hopefully
will be useful
uh to some of you dealing with
disinformation in your local communities
in your households even based on the
calls i got last week
the flu case fatality rate the cfr
is about 0.1 percent the covid
case fatality rate is 3.1 percent that's
31 times higher 31 times higher
than the flu now you might say wait
david what do you mean 3.1
i thought that the the death rate of
covid was only 0.8 percent
remember we've got different metrics
here we're talking about the case
fatality rate that is deaths
divided by known cases known
cases because of the number of unknown
and never tested coveted cases for a
variety of reasons
it is believed that the infection
fatality rate is 0.8 percent but here
we're comparing
the case fatality rate of flu and the
case fatality rate of covid
3.1 percent for covid 0.1 percent for
flu
31 times higher okay so that comparison
is
weird um then you have
how infectious are they r zero
which is the or the r naught is a
measure
of how infectious how easily spreadable
a condition is
the r naught for the flu is somewhere
between
one and two for covid the r
naught was originally believed to be
somewhat higher
without taking any mitigation measures
so probably in the area of
two to four and the whole point of the
mitigation measures was try to get it
below one so it stops spreading
and the delta variant is believed to be
way more contagious
we're still learning but it could be
something like five to seven we're not
totally sure but the delta variant is
dramatically more contagious so the flu
comparisons
all would point to taking kovid really
serious
way more deadly and way more contagious
than the flu
now of course if you say well let's i
want to compare it to something like
ebola something really deadly
it is absolutely true that ebola is
really deadly ebola
kills the the death rate of ebola really
varies depending on the medical
facilities that are available there
it's also a much smaller sample size but
ebola's death rate is estimated
at 25 to 90 percent of those infected
the infection fatality rate
of ebola is an average is about 50
percent
now a big portion of that is because of
where ebola happens
ebola overwhelmingly takes place in
poorer countries
where people often end up dying of shock
from fluid loss
that would likely be lower if ebola was
only in a country like the united states
because of more advanced medicine and
access to more advanced medicine
but there's no doubt covid is way way
less deadly than ebola
but it's way more contagious ebola
is transmitted by bodily fluids and it
has an r naught of between one and a
half and two and a half
coveted and especially the delta variant
are way more contagious than ebola
because of how it spreads so the point
here is
when someone like ron johnson says oh
you know i'd think about a vaccine
mandate if we had a really serious
deadly virus spreading
what exactly does he mean how deadly and
how contagious
we have to be asking that because when
they say oh flu flew
well hold on a second let's figure that
out because you could have something
that's way more deadly but way less
contagious
and you could have a similar expected
death toll because you're going to have
fewer infections because it doesn't
spread as easily
with a higher death rate and you could
have the same number or more people
die my instinct is everything i just
said
isn't even a factor when someone like
ron johnson says this my guess is he'll
say
i would look at a vaccine mandate if we
had a serious disease spreading
and then he would go to him and you
would say okay tell us exactly
what an imag what disease combination of
are not
and death rate would qualify as serious
in your mind and my instinct is he'll
move on to the next talking point
i don't think they actually really know
what they're saying they're just coming
up with something
to not have to be in favor of a vaccine
mandate now
and then if there was a different
situation he'd come up with a different
reason to oppose it these guys are
clueless is the point that i'm trying to
make
we are now going to talk about florida
what is going on in florida
florida has quickly become a coveted
hellscape
we are seeing more cases basically in
all of the united states as i mentioned
earlier
in part it's because of the more
contagious delta variant
and in part it's because not nearly
enough people have been vaccinated
if you can believe it as of yesterday
afternoon
only 49.6 percent of the united states
has been fully vaccinated we are not
even at 50 percent yet even though
vaccines are
widely available safe and free
they are free so cases are spiking in
lots of places
but in many of these places
hospitalizations are not
spiking nearly as much or at all because
of the high vaccination rate so like
vermont would be one such example and
there are many that you can find
the u.s state of florida which has
become a cartoonish
trumpian farce led by republican
governor ron desantis
was hit not only uh has hit not only
a new single day pandemic long case
record
but it has also reached a record level
of covet hospitalization
right now today right now as we are
recording today's show
there is a record number of
hospitalization for covid in the state
of florida
what is ron desantis doing he is trying
to ban
any kind of mask mandates and get
everybody in school
now as you can see here florida is
setting
its own new single day case record they
did it on july 31st
with almost 22 000 cases depending on
the
day florida is regularly registering
between
20 and 30 percent of the entire
country's new cases that's in one state
the state of florida
but if it were merely cases among
vaccinated people for whom it's mostly a
cold
it wouldn't be that big of a deal but
florida's hospitals are completely
filling up
first of all check out the positivity
rates in florida
which are 18.1 percent for the state in
broward county
it's a 14 positivity rate miami-dade 12
percent
monroe county 16 positivity
if your positivity rate is above about
five
it means you're not testing nearly
enough and you're not capturing
nearly enough of the people who are sick
when when you have an 18
positivity rate it means there's tons of
people not getting tested
who have the virus and are spreading the
virus and then maybe most importantly
hospitalizations are at a record the
associated press
reporting that florida breaks covet 19
hospitalization record with more than 10
200 patients the sunshine state
had 10 207 people hospitalized with
confirmed covet cases
according to data reported to the u.s
department of hhs
the previous record was from july 23 of
2020
more than half a year before
vaccinations were widespread so
understand that hospitalization today in
florida
is about 20 percent higher than before
anybody
was vaccinated florida is now leading
the nation
in per capita hospitalization some
people saying well david sir
florida has so many people yes but
florida is also leading
per capita hospitalizations in the last
week
florida is averaging 1500 adult
hospitalizations a day
and listen to this 35 pediatric
hospitalizations every day 35
kids in florida are being put into the
hospital with covid
and then what about deaths well because
part of florida is vaccinated
we don't expect the death rate to get as
high but deaths are also climbing in
florida much more than nationally
uh daily deaths in florida they were
down to 22 a day they're now up to 55 a
day more than doubled
and based on the recent case explosion
we would expect dramatically higher
death counts in florida
in the next 15 to 20 days meanwhile
governor ron desantis
is almost campaigning for the virus
bragging about we're not going to do
mask mandates we're not going to do
guidelines
we're never shutting anything down we're
opening everything do everything
send kids to school but no masks in
school if you were trying
to have the worst numbers in the country
you'd basically be doing what ron
desantis is doing in florida
will it get him uh negative consequences
or will he end up as the republican
presidential nominee in 2024.
that's the question and because we do
have a real problem in this country with
ignorance
i am not ready to say this will
definitely hurt ron desantis it's
it's possible that somehow because of
the republican electorate
ron desantis comes out of this looking
like a freedom-loving hero
rather than a coveted hellscape creating
lunatic
um remains to be seen we'll have more
on the explosive situation in florida
on our instagram you can find us on
instagram at davidpakmanshow
and find me on instagram david.pakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming
a member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show the regular show with
no commercials
you also get access to our entire
archive of every episode dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21
for a huge discount join pacman.com
we knew and we said it was going to take
a while
to learn the full scope of the
corruption
and attempted coercion and possible
criminality of the last administration
we knew we certainly didn't know
everything
on january 20th when donald trump left
office
and just about every week certainly
every month
we have learned more and more in
particular about the efforts that the
trump administration went to to try to
steal
the 2020 election in the period between
november and january
there is a stunning stunning new report
from the new york times where it is now
known
that donald trump went to the justice
department
and pressed them to declare the election
results corrupt
trump wanted them to say this was a
corrupt election
to then allow trump to we don't even
know
that's the really scary part let's look
at this
important article president donald trump
pressed top justice department officials
late last year to declare that the
election was corrupt
even though they had found no instances
of widespread fraud so he and his allies
in congress could use the assertion to
try to overturn the results
according to new documents provided to
lawmakers the demands were an
extraordinary instance of a president
interfering with an agency that is
typically more independent from the
white house
to advance his personal agenda they are
also the latest example of trump's
wide-ranging campaign during his final
weeks in office to delegitimize the
election results remember
william barr said in an interview and
certainly privately as well we found no
evidence
that fraud or or improper actions
related to the election
impacted the results in any way that
that's what the doj actually found
the article goes on to say listen to
this the exchange unfolded during a
phone call on december 27th in which
trump
pressed the acting attorney general
jeffrey rosen and his deputy richard
donahue
on voter fraud claims that the justice
depart department had found no evidence
for
mr donohue warned that the department
had no power to change
the outcome of the election how many
people told trump that
pence doj trump replied he did not
expect that
according to notes mr donahue took
memorializing the conversation
just say the election was corrupt and
leave the rest to me and to
congressional allies
donahue wrote in summarizing trump's
response
trump was hoping that if the doj could
just say it was all corrupt
then trump and his republican friends
would figure out
some way to use that to i guess try to
prevent joe biden from actually taking
office
mr trump did not name the lawmakers but
at other points during the call he
mentioned jim jordan
republican of ohio whom he described as
a fighter
consider that jim jordan
was named as one of the five members of
the house
that kevin mccarthy wanted to put on
this commission to investigate what
happened on january 6th
this is more evidence that jim jordan
was more of an accomplice
than anything he could be as an
investigator
has no business on that committee um
representative scott perry
who at the time promoted the idea that
the election was stolen from trump
senator ron johnson who trump praised
for getting to the bottom of things mr
jordan and mr johnson denied any role
in trump's efforts to pressure the
justice department
russell dies a spokesman for jordan
remember jordan voted to overturn the
election results in key
states congressman jordan did not and
has not and would not pressure anyone
at the justice department about the 2020
election
mr johnson had no conversations with
president trump about the doj
questioning the election results
said his spokeswoman alexa henning she
noted he had acknowledged
joseph biden as the president-elect but
that he also called for what he sees as
erectional
erection election irregularities that's
my chuck schumer moment
to be fully investigated and addressed
to restore confidence in future
elections
perry did not respond to requests for
comment he has continued to assert trump
won
but has not been tied directly to the
white house to keep him
in office so listen um i actually don't
think there was really a master plan
here
um i don't think trump has the foresight
or the organization
to really do this in an organized manner
my sense is trump had the idea he could
coordinate and put all of this stuff
together
um let's let's get you know rudy and
other people going around making claims
and filing
court motions let's get the doj to say
it was corrupt
let's talk about getting people active
on january 6.
trump might have had the idea that he
could put it all together as some kind
of master plan
i don't believe trump is actually
capable of that his
general demeanor seems to have been if i
can just
get people even if those people don't
really have the legal authority to
change anything related to the election
rudy going around get doj to say it was
corrupt
get you know brad raffensberger and
georgia to say we found these
maybe he could put it all together wrap
it up and tie it with a bow and somehow
remain
president now he was probably closer
to pulling it off than we would like to
admit and what i mean by that is
imagine if the rioters the terrorists
the insurrectionists on january 6th
had actually gotten to a democratic
congress member and held them hostage
or gotten to mike pence they may have
been successful
in preventing the certification of that
election for a little bit of time
now in a sense they delayed it hours
they delayed it
hours but not days had they actually
taken a hostage which
which we believe many of them wanted to
do they might have actually been able to
delay it further
and consider how many times trump was
told by different officials
you're being told false information
none of the things you're saying are
true and trump
still would respond effectively with i
don't care
i don't care just say it's stolen and
i'll figure out a way to use it to try
to keep the grift
going and then of course that also gets
to
what a lot of this is about which it's
been used by trump to continue
raising money but that's the news the
sitting president pressured the
department of justice
to say the election was corrupt that is
an attempt to destroy our democracy
if he had gotten his way and if he had
got if he had gotten someone at the doj
to say that
and then he had used that to say the
election was corrupt it's invalid
and i am going to what declare martial
law some kind of state of emergency
whatever he was ginning up with mike
lindell the my pillow guy at the white
house that day
that would have been a step towards the
dictator that donald trump very much
wants to be and
think back i mean consider what we now
know and then think back to when bill
clinton had a conversation with loretta
lynch
and that was like a big right-wing
scandal you might not even remember that
and it seems laughable that that would
even count as a scandal
given what the former administration
tried to do it's absolutely
crazy and next i want to talk about
what's been going on
with the infrastructure bill which also
sent trump into a tizzy
i have said a few times now joe biden
must get another major piece of
legislation done
this calendar year 2021 or it's going to
be a really tough uphill battle
in the midterms the midterms are not a
foregone conclusion
traditionally almost always when a party
takes a white house in an election year
two years later in the first
midterm they don't do well in the
midterms that's typically the way it
goes
in most cases i don't believe that it is
necessarily going to go that way in 2022
but it could
and joe biden needs a major legislative
accomplishment
fortunately for america there has been
major progress on the infrastructure
bill that democrats have been trying to
figure out how on earth can we move
forward on this with republicans
this is great news for the country it's
good news for democrats
but it's apparently disastrous news for
the former president donald trump
who has blown a gasket over this
attacking republicans now mind you
so far all that's happened is that late
last week republicans in the senate
went along with starting to debate the
infrastructure bill they've not even
voted on the package yet okay they're
just starting the process right now
that alone has donald trump absolutely
losing it
trump putting out a statement quote
under the weak
leadership of mitch mcconnell senate
republicans continue to lose
he lost arizona he lost georgia weird i
don't remember mitch mcconnell being on
the ballot there
he ignored election fraud and he doesn't
fight
now he's giving democrats everything
they want and getting nothing in return
no deal is better than a bad deal
fight for america not for special
interests and radical democrats
rhinos are ruining america right
alongside
communist democrats i don't know if
there's anything that's accurate
in that it has real old man
yelling at a cloud energy to it if you
notice
but think through the things he's saying
there
first of all how is it that mitch
mcconnell lost arizona and georgia
it was trump who lost arizona and
georgia
he was the candidate mitch mcconnell was
on the ballot
in kentucky only where he won now maybe
trump is referring to
mitch mcconnell's poor leadership led to
republican senators
losing in arizona and in short in
georgia i believe trump is more
responsible than mitch mcconnell for
those losses
as well makes absolutely no sense and by
the way
when donald trump spent several years
insulting the late senator john mccain
who was very popular in arizona did that
help her hurt trump
in arizona but it was somehow mitch
mcconnell's fault trump barely won in
2016
eeked it out just barely winning in a
few states
lost the popular vote insulted key
people in key states
failed on kovid alienated nearly half
the country
and he thinks it couldn't be his fault
that he and his republican colleagues
lost
in arizona and georgia and if they did
it's someone else's fault for sure like
it's really really
a complete inability to take
responsibility for
anything now there's a ton of words in
trump's statement about this but it can
be translated in this way
i'm really mad that republicans are
going to go along
and give joe biden an accomplishment
because it makes me look bad because i
couldn't get infrastructure done
that's the translation of what trump is
saying and it's not even just that
trump has been pushing republicans to
reject the deal
and not work with democrats and
republicans at least for now
are signaling we'll do it or we might do
it it depends on how the debate actually
goes over the bill
and for all the slamming liz cheney
and others as being rhinos republicans
in name only
those republicans seem much more on the
same page with each other than with
trump on almost every issue it's
wild how trump as the outlier
gets to call the others republicans in
name only so the real story here is
trump fails to see his own involvement
in the total loss of power that
republicans have experienced
the buck never seems to stop with trump
when it's not convenient
under trump republicans lost the house
in 2018 they lost the senate in 2020
they lost the white house in 2020 but
mitch mcconnell is responsible for the
states trump lost
and trump actually won anyway now back
to infrastructure
i really hope that a bill gets done
trump is furious because the senate
reaching an infrastructure deal under
biden rather than under trump
which is something he promised to do
makes him look bad and that's true it
makes him look bad
and that's all that this is donald
trump's preference
how is this patriotic trump's preference
is for american infrastructure to
crumble for four more years
if it means he can get reelected and
then sign an infrastructure bill
in 2025 he would rather infrastructure
crumble for four years
than for joe biden to get a bill done
that's not patriotic that's just about
donald trump
and it's a reminder that he knows deep
down he's not a winner
he wanted a big bipartisan agreement
biden's the one who's
maybe going to get it done instead trump
was feckless during his presidency
and he's now furious bottom line the
country needs the infrastructure deal
it would be good for the country in and
of itself as
improvements to infrastructure it would
be good economically
and it would be good if you want to make
a political analysis joe biden needs
another major accomplishment in 21.
let's see how the debate goes let's see
whether the bill
gets done and how quickly it happens
my sense is particularly with the
congressional break coming up
we're probably looking at september
october but the fact that they're
starting to debate
is a very good thing make sure you're
following us on facebook at facebook.com
david pakman show we'll have more on
this story there
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show
so this you have to see that this is
just bizarre
um donald trump's former chief of staff
mark meadows
a horrible person with no morals
whatsoever one of the biggest liars and
signal boosters of lies during trump's
administration
mark meadows went on newsmax's show
cortes and pellegrino
over the weekend and said that donald
trump
is he's he said president donald trump
is meeting with cabinet members to talk
about
moving forward in a real way what
so in other words former president
donald trump
is meeting with people because he has no
cabinet
to talk about something that we don't
really fully understand i mean what what
does it even mean
meeting with cabinet members check out
this absolute and utter insanity claire
we've been here
actually working on uh what comes next
uh
not only in 2024 but how we win
back the house in 2022 and some of these
state houses like virginia so it's it's
been a very productive
a couple of days i'm still here at
bedminster as you know
but wanted to to join you to talk about
uh really a president that is fully
engaged
highly focused and and remaining on on
task
chief do you want to break any news from
your meetings with president trump
well we met with some of our cabinet
members tonight we actually had a
follow-up member meeting with some of
our cabinet members and as we were
looking at that
we're looking at what does come next i
i'm not
authorized to speak on behalf of the
president okay but i but i can tell you
this steve
uh we wouldn't be meeting tonight if we
weren't making plans to move forward in
a real way
and with president trump at the head of
that ticket
i like it well hey you can't you can't
blame me for fishing a little bit there
right
what is he talking about moving forward
in a real way
with president trump and his cabinet
like it's
the language implies that
meadows is alluding to some kind of
shadow presidency
a parallel presidency to joe biden or
that donald trump is
actually still the president that that's
what the language implies
it's possible that meadows is just using
weird language and he just means
the former president is talking with
potential cabinet members
about a future run for the presidency or
something like that like maybe
that that would be a more sane thing to
be saying
uh or maybe mark meadows is referring to
this absurd idea of a reinstatement
that's been floating that's supposed to
happen in august by the way
it's august do we know what day it's
supposed to happen or maybe now it's
september which of course
it's not happening in august it's not
happening in september
if trump were more organized if you
heard something like this from mark
meadows
you might think whoa this is almost
starting to sound
kind of like pre-civil war type rhetoric
like he's talking about some kind of
takeover of some kind um you know
i i don't know that trump is actually
that organized the daily beasts molly
jong fast
had a hilarious tweet about this aside
from like the absurdity of a cabinet
member
for a guy who's not even president molly
tweeted quote
trump didn't president when he was
president the idea
somehow that somehow he'd do it now is
kind of mind-boggling which is pretty on
the nose like this guy didn't work
for the last eight months of his
presidency now we're supposed to believe
he's holding meetings and actually doing
work it makes up
absolutely no sense but understand that
we see this you and i i mean let's not
you if you're
one of my trolls but you and i the the
figurative you and i
we see this and we laugh and we say this
is so bonkers
but there are i mean millions there are
tens of millions of people
who see this and believe it 100 percent
some variation of trump is still somehow
wielding power
the military is under trump's control a
reinstatement is possible
the election results will be overturned
like not everybody believes
all of those things but you've got tens
of millions of people in this country
who believe
some of that now in any case whatever
kind of moving forward
mark meadows is talking about hopefully
this time law enforcement
as well as intelligence agencies and the
military are ready
if moving forward is going to look
anything like it looked on january 6.
that's the concern from the standpoint
of public safety now also by the way
cabinet members i would love to know who
trump is meeting with and i don't mean
of course they're not cabinet members of
a shadow cabinet but what i mean is
by the end of trump's presidency even
much of his own cabinet was pretty
lukewarm about donald trump
the ones that didn't leave you know
people like rex tillerson and others who
left early
of course they now are disgusted with
with trump maybe they were all along
they don't deserve praise for that it's
just hey you shouldn't have gone along
with it to begin with
eventually they figured that out the
ones that didn't leave
i mean you know like is is former
secretary of education
betsy devos meeting with donald trump in
florida or new jersey or wherever he is
like who is even meeting with donald
trump
at this point that's a really curious
thing
and the best thing trump could do now
you know
if trump really wanted to appear
as not a completely out of his mind
unable to accept reality child
there is something trump could do and i
would respect him for doing it it
wouldn't mean i would agree with other
things but
i would say if trump did this i would
say i respect that he did it even though
it would be for self-centered reasons
trump should record a psa one minute
video
no equivocation simply saying
my fellow americans this is donald trump
we must end the pandemic i got
vaccinated in january
the vaccine is safe it was developed
during my administration
it was approved by my fda and it is time
for you to do your patriotic duty
for the maga movement get vaccinated
today we have all the vaccines we want
i need you to do me a favor though
remember that language
go and get yourself vaccinated it would
be one minute it would be super simple
it's the best thing trump could do for
the country and you know what
in all seriousness it's undeniable
that part of the reason that more people
haven't gotten vaccinated
is because they see joe biden as the guy
administering the rollout of the
vaccines and they are trump people
and they believe all sorts of horrible
things about joe biden okay
so if trump were to do such a video
a bunch of his followers would get
vaccinated and trump could then
accurately say i am partially
responsible for getting these people
vaccinated because i told them to go and
i did the psa
he would be right i would actually not
only respect trump for doing it
i would grant him these people are so
nuts
they weren't going to get vaccinated
until they heard it come out of your
mouth that they should go and do it
in in completely unequivocal terms he
could actually take
credit for something he is deserving of
credit for
normally trump shifts blame away for
things he is responsible for
that he doesn't want credit for and
takes credit for things that have
nothing to do with him trump could do a
one-minute psa
it would lead to millions of
vaccinations not every i know not
everybody
not all of these people will go and do
it but millions would
and then he could actually take credit
for something positive that he did
instead
he's in this bizarre make-believe
portion
of his post-presidency delusional period
it's starting to get reminiscent of that
fred trump fake office that was set up i
don't know if people remember this
story that's been told um when trump's
dad fred trump was struggling with
serious cognitive issues
uh basically it was almost like a set
his office was kind of turned into a set
in that he would have papers put in
front of him every day to sign and stuff
he thought he was working
his phone only went out to his secretary
he thought he was working but he really
wasn't he was almost it was almost like
the truman show in a sense
um great great film by the way uh that
that's that's sort of like what is
becoming reminiscent trump
trump's having a meeting and people sit
around the table like a cabinet but joe
biden's president it's starting to get
both sad
and disturbingly delusional
one person that loves what is going on
in terms of the debate around uh
who is the real president and who should
be meeting with the republicans
is madison cawthorne madison cawthorne
unfortunately for him was caught trying
to board a plane with a gun and you're
not supposed to do that even if you're a
member of congress
okay i don't think if i came to you
and i said sir sir sure
someone a member of the house has tried
to board a plane carrying a gun
would you would you be shocked to learn
that that individual
is part of the pro-trump anti-science
wing of the republican party i would not
be shocked by that and indeed that is
the case it is madison cawthorne
madison cawthorne had his gun
confiscated
by airport police he is now facing a
federal fine okay
and the loss of a special security
status this actually happened a few
months ago february 13th
uh cawthorne was already a member of
congress at the time
he went to the airport asheville airport
north carolina
tsa found an unloaded gun in his
carry-on bag along with a loaded
magazine now defenders will say well but
hold on a second the la the gun wasn't
loaded
he's still breaking the law you are
allowed to transport
unloaded firearms in a checked bag
he had a glock nine millimeter handgun
as it's described in documents in his
carry-on along with a loaded magazine
readily accessible to him during the
flight that is against the law
that is an easily loadable gun in the
cabin
imagine if someone went through security
with a loaded gun
and was told no no no you can't bring it
on the plane with you like that just
unload it and then put both parts in the
bag
and then you can get on no that would
never fly
now a spokesman responded to questions
saying
this was all just a big mistake madison
cawthorne
didn't realize that the gun was there
now i'm gonna get to that in a second
because that's actually quite
problematic
how frequently does this happen this
year so far eight firearms were reported
at the checkpoint
no criminal charges were filed in any of
those cases what happened with madison
cawthorne's gun is that it was secured
at the airport and he got it after
his flight there are actually some
recordings an officer can be heard
repeating a few times to another officer
there's a gun elected official with a
gun elected official with a firearm
police then have a conversation about
what to do at one point they
say maybe have him take it out to his
car he only apparently had
seven minutes before his flight so they
said we'll hold on to it for you
we'll secure it you can get it when you
come back i'm glad they made everything
so convenient for him right
now different airports in different
states have different rules
tsa spokesman mark howell said in new
york they perp walk you out of the
airport in handcuffs
on the other hand in georgia you can
open carry anywhere this took place in
asheville
in nearby charlotte north carolina
police normally charge people with guns
under a city ordinance
um it's not totally clear what typically
happens
in asheville it's not yet clear whether
madison cawthron got
special treatment now it's definitely
possible that this was an accident
at the same time madison cawthorne is
one of two or three members of the
congress
who were prominently bragging around the
time of the trump riots
that they are armed on the floor of the
house to protect themselves
where guns are also not allowed so in
order to believe that this was
an accident or an oversight first of all
we have to believe that the guy
who knowingly brings his guns where they
aren't allowed the floor of the house
unknowingly did the exact same thing
when it came to the cabin of an airplane
okay so that you tell me what you
believe as far as that goes
but there's another issue this is not an
example of responsible gun ownership
what i mean
by that is gun owners should know
at all times where is each
firearm rather than being unaware that
you've got a gun in your bag
because if you're unaware whether the
gun is in your bag you might be unaware
that one of your guns is loaded
and you're supposed to know the status
and location of every single gun you
have
at every time my friends who have
firearms
have theirs locked unless in transit
or in use if you're careless with them
that's how you get accidental injury
and death so if the true story is
kawthorne
really didn't know the gun was in his
carry-on
that's not responsible because he was
unaware of the location of his firearm
so
a whole bunch of questions here it also
raises questions about
he was intending to fly was he flying to
a different state
what was his relationship to a license
to have the gun in that other state or
was he flying from asheville to
somewhere in north carolina
we just don't know all of the answers
here yet but we're supposed to believe
it was all just a big mistake nothing to
worry about
no big deal here except you know he also
claims to have brought guns on the floor
of the house
which you're not allowed to do really
disturbing stuff
we have a voicemail number that you can
call anytime that number is 219
to david p here is a caller
really mad this by the way oh the san
antonio troll
he's mad at me again about
things i haven't actually said about
vaccines take a listen to this
hey pac-man i wanted to call and talk to
you about the vaccines oh i bet you got
super giddy didn't you
okay i'm telling you uh the other trolls
in your audience
uh to go ahead and get it and i have a
bone to pick with you about this
i think that an issue like uh
moving the country past coronavirus is
something that
she easily should be able to knight us
unite us but no
you want to divide us by it by making
issues summing your nose at the other
side for not getting the vaccine
no in fact on this show i've made it
clear we need to figure out ways
to just get people to want to get
vaccinated just just
insulting or attacking i don't know what
show this guy's watching but his thing
is he always calls me
and argues that things i've not said
were a really really bad idea to say
there's better ways to do it there's
reasons people are on the fence about it
yeah
and there's better ways to bring them
over
uh to the side of vaccines than mocking
them
calling them dumb and calling them
unintelligent just so you can line your
pockets and get those clicks
what's this guy talking about not
everything has to be democrat good
republican bad
no that's true it's just overwhelmingly
republicans that don't want to get
vaccinated
the one factor that most predicts
whether you will or won't get vaccinated
is are you a trump supporter
that that's the number one slice that we
find i mean
it's not me making it that way this
issue shouldn't be
political and you have done nothing but
politicize it
you are just as bad as these morons on
the right saying it's going to turn you
into a pink zombie
it's going to alter your dna into some
mind-controlled uh robot that is that
bidens you know
me saying we've really got to figure out
a way how to get these people vaccinated
that's the same as saying the vaccine
will
change your dna that's that's a weird
assertion that biden's fee at biden's
fingertips
you're just as bad as these people you
saying that the government should kick
down your door and
and i've never said that force people to
take the vaccine
that's insanity never said and telling
people they're
morons for not taking there's better
ways to do it most people
don't believe the nonsense on the far
right about this all right so anyway
that's the san antonio troll
um he will he
will levy blistering critiques against
things i've not actually said on the
show
uh we are going to talk about the
provincetown cluster
a lot of misinformation about the
provincetown covid situation
we will talk about it on today's bonus
show we will talk about why doordash
drivers are on strike
i am boycotting doordash i will tell you
why on today's bonus show
and we will also talk about the
settlement of the zoom bombing lawsuit
for 85
million dollars all of those stories and
more
on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com
pakman